اثار قرار الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات في تونس وقف الحملات الدعائيه
الممهده لانتخابات المجلس التاسيسي اثار
جدلا في اوساط القوى والاحزاب السياسيه
ورفض البعض الالتزام به
نطاق الجدل في تونس ليطال صلاحيه المجلس
التاسيسي المقرر انتخاب الشهر المقبل ان
من يريدها محصوره في كتابه الدستور ومن
يريدها صلاحيات كامله
تتجاوز ذلك
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين
من المخاوف التي تؤسس لهذا الجدل مع
اقتراب البلاد من اول استحقاقات الثوره
ومع خطوره هذه التباينات على افاق التحول
الديمقراطي في تونس وما سبل احتوائها
اهلا بكم يستعد التونسيون لاول استحقاقات
ثورتهم التي اطاحت بنظام زين العابدين بن
علي قبل ثمانيه اشهر ففي الثالث والعشرين
من الشهر المقبل سيدعى الناخبون للمشاركه
في اختيار اعضاء المجلس الوطني التاسيسي
وتثير صلاحيات المجلس المنتظر جدلا واسعا
في الاوساط التونسيه بين من يريدها قاصره
على المهمه الاساسيه المتمثله في كتابه
الدستور جديد للجمهوريه التونسيه
ومن يرى توسيع هذه الصلاحيات لتشمل تعيين
الحكومه وغيرها من القضايا
[موسيقى]
جاؤوا للمشاركه في اجتماع ينادي ب تنظيم
استفتاء موازن لانتخابات المجلس التاسيسي
في تونس دون علم مستقل بفحوى
يقولون ان المنظمين اغروهم بالمال
والاعانه منظم التظاهره هو هذا الرجل
المصنف كاحد المنظرين للاستفتاء وابرز
المدافعين عن هما مشاركه في ذلك احزاب مثل
الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي والاتحاد الوطني
الحر ووجوه واحزاب اخرى تصنف ضمن بقايا
النظام ال بن علي يقولون ان هذا الاستفتاء
يدعو الى تحديد مده قيام المجلس التاسيسي
والحد من صلاحياته وهو الضامن باراده
الشعب في تقرير مصيره دعوه الاستفتاء وليس
غايه في حد ذاته ولكن ميشيل الهدف منه هو
القطع امام كل الاشكال الدكتاتوريه التي
يمكن ان تحصل اه في تونس ما بعد الثوره
نحن نعتقد انه المجلس التاسيسي لم تحدد
بعد مد وهذا امر خطير اعتقد كذلك لم تحدد
صلاحياته وهذا امر خطير في الوقت الذي مات
فيه الحكومه بنفسها عن الخلاف الدائر حول
تنظيم الاستفتاء من عدمه تعارض احزاب
كثيره على راسها حركه النهضه والمؤتمر من
اجل الجمهوريه وحزب العمال الشيوعي هذا
الخيار بل وترى في تحجيم صلاحيات المجلس
التاسيسي انقلابا على الديمقراطيه وخوفا
من صناديق الاقتراع المطالبه باستفتاء حول
هذا المجلس هي محاوله للالتفاف على هذا
المجلس و للالتفاف على الديمقراطيه اصلا
ان نتساءل من هي هذه الاطراف وتدعو
الاستفتاء هي اطراف اه ت جمعيه اه هي
اطراف لم تساهم في الحقيقه الامر في هذه
الثورات اه هي اطراف تخشى من المسوره
للتاسيسي رجال القانون من جانبها يقولون
ان اجراء هذا الاستفتاء غير ممكن حاليا
باعتبار انه سيؤثر على عمل المؤسسه
الشرعيه الوحيده في فتره ما بعد الثالث
والعشرين من اكتوبر وكذلك لعدم توفر شروط
يبدو الاسد دائما في الظاهر هو افضل طريقه
للتعبير عن الاراده الشعبيه بصفه مباشره
ولكن الاستفتاء يمكن ان يتحول بسرعه الى
اداه للسطو على هذه الاراده الشعبيه يجب
ان تتوفر في كل عمليه استثنائيه جمله من
الشروط الموضوعيه اعتقد انها اليوم غير
متوفره الاستفتاء هل هو حق اريد به باطل ف
بعض الاطراف تقول انه ضامن لاراده الشعب
والبعض الاخر يرى فيه التفافا عليها وبين
هذا وذاك بدا الحديث عن مبادرات لراب
الصدع بين الطرفين حافظ فريق الجزيره
تونس
وينضم الينا لمناقشه هذه القضيه من تونس
العاصمه عصام الشابي عضو المكتب السياسي
للحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي
ومن باريس ينضم الينا الدكتور منصف
المرزوقي رئيس حزب المؤتمر من اجل
الجمهوريه اهلا بكما وابدا معك سيد عصام
الشابي اه الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي الذي
انت عضو في مكتبه سياسي رفض اه وبصراحه اه
رفضا قاطعا قرار منع الاشعار السياسي واكد
انه مستعد للوقوف من القضاء من اجل ذلك ما
هي دواسه الحزب
الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي حزب يحترم
القانون ويتقيد به لكنه يرفض الانتقال
لقرارات اعتباطيه وارتجاليه نحن مع
احترامنا للهيئه المستقله للانتخابات
فاننا نعتبر قرار منع الاشهار والدعايه
السياسيه ابتداء من يوم
سبتمبر هو قرار لقانون الهيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات من حتى نفسها
الصلاحيات لا تمتلكها فهي مخوله للاشراف
على الحمله الانتخابيه التي هي تبقى
المرسوم المنظمه الانتخابات تبتدئ يوم
اكتوبر وتنتهي يوما واحد قبل الاقتراع
ونحن لا نرى كيف وما هي المبادرات التي
سمحت الهيئه لنفسها ل تمد يدها على فتره
الدعايه السياسيه الحزبيه التي نحن بصددها
الان من اين تستمد هذه الهيئه هذه
الصلاحيه نحن نعتقد ان قرارها كان
ارتجاليا لم ينبنى على تشاور وكان م جانبا
سيدتي القانون نعم سيدتي ال قانون
الانتخاب يقول ان الحمله الانتخابيه كما
اسلفت تبتدئ يوم 2 اكتوبر القادم وفي هذه
الحمله تتولى الهيئه المستقله للانتخابات
ضمن المستويات بين كل المطر المترشحين لكن
قبل ذلك نحن بصدد التعريف باحزاب ن او
برنامجنا ونقوم بالدعايه الضروريه لذلك
حتى نتمكن من تعريف بانفسنا وبرامجنا لدى
الناخبين والقانون ال المرسوم الذي احدث
الهيئه المستقله للانتخابات حدد لها بكل
دقه مجال تدخلها وصلاحياتها اما ان تسمح
الهيئه اثناء هذه الفتره بان تمدد في
الحمله الانتخابيه وفي فتره الحمله
الانتخابيه وتقدمها ثلاثه اسابيع قبل
موعدها ونحن نعتبره محاوله للتضييق على
الاحزاب وللحد من فضائيه الحوار والدعايه
الح والحال ان المرحله ما قبل انتخابيه
تقتضي توفير اكثر ما يمكن من هذه
الفضائيات حتى تتمكن الاحزاب السياسيه في
تونس في هذه المرحله الدقيقه من الاتصال
بالمواطنين ومن استعمال كل وسائل الاتصال
والدعايه للوصول الى هؤلاء المواطنين الذي
الذين اذكر ان نصفهم تقريبا اليوم لم يحدد
بعد اختياره بل ان قرابه النصف ايضا لا ي
لا يعرف ولا يميز بين الاحزاب المتنافسه
كيف يمكن اليوم ان نطلبه الاحزاب ان تكف
عن الدعايه ثلاثه اسابيع قبل الحمله
الانتخابيه اللهم الا اذا اردنا ان يسوي
من الاسفل بين الاحزاب الدعوه بان هذه ان
هذا القرار هو يسوى بين الاحزاب هو في
حقيقه الامر محاوله لتقييد وتكبيل عمل
الاحزاب ولخلق ضوابط نحن لا نرى انفسهم
مضطرين او مجبورين للقبول بها نحن في
الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي وصلنا العمل لا
مكانا بصوره طبيعيه
حملتنا الدعائيه ونعتبر ان قرار الهيئه
قرار لا قانوني وطلبنا منها انهيارات خلال
ذلك ان تنتج للقضاء ونحن مستعدين للدفاع
الموقف دكتور المنصف المرزوقي
هذا القرار
منع الاشهار السياسي او الاعلان السياسيه
من هنا الى غايه اه بدايه اكتوبر المقبل
الا يحقق برايك الهدف ال المعلن من وهو
وضع كل التشكيلات السياسيه والاحزاب
السياسيه على قدم المساواه
انه يقول انه الشعب التونسي ينتظر هذه
اللحظه موضوع اكثر من ستين سنه نحن امام
اللحظه التاريخيه التي هي تاسيس لمجتمع
جديد لدوله جديده و هذه اللحظه اعتبرناها
يعني وهي ما دفع لها الناس من ثمن باهض
كما ت من اجلها الناس تحت التعذيب كما ذهب
من اجلها اه الاف والاف من السجون كما
انتظرها اكثر من نصف قرن وبالتالي هذه
اللحظه هي لحظه تاسيسيه تاريخيه في بلادهم
المفروض ان نواجهها بكل هيبه واحد ولا
اقول حتى يعني هذه لحظه مفصليه في تاريخ
بلادنا للاسف الشديد م اذا لاحظنا لاحظنا
اولا انه ظهور ظاهره الاشهار السياسي وهي
لم تكن معروفه وهذه ظاهره يعني تضرب هيبه
السياسه عندما تجعل من السياسيه ومن الحزب
السياسي يتصرف كانه رجل يعني رجل اه يبيع
او يبيع في نفس الفضاءات التي تباع فيها
الا غلط والبلدات ثم وراء هذه الظاهره
ظاهره الاشاره السياسي هناك ظاهره اخطر من
هذا بكثير وهي ظاهره المال السياسي لان
سيدتي الكريمه المؤتمر من اجل الجمهوريه
وحزب ال اه نشر ميزانيته كامله وهذه
الميزانيه لا تفوت اربعه وثلاثين الف
دينار بينما هذه الاشارات تكلف ملايين
الدينارات وبالتالي الموضوع من اين تاتي
هذه الاموال نحن طلبنا من هذا الحزب ومن
بقيه الاحزاب انت يعني ان تقول للشعب
التونسي انها تاتي هذه الاموال والى حد
الان لم نتلقى اي اي الجواب وهذا هذه
العمليه عمليه المال السياسي التي وراء
هذا الاشهار هي عمليه تضرب وهيبه
الديمقراطيه لان الديمقراطيه لا تكون
بالفساد واخيرا لا اخرا يعني هناك ايضا
وضرب هيبه القانون لانه في اخر المطاف هذه
الهيئه العليا للهيئه العليا التي ت
وافقنا عليها يعني قبلنا بان تكون نوع من
البرلمان المؤقت الذي يضبط كل عملنا
وبالتالي فان رفض هذا الحزب الحزب
الديمقراطي التقدمي التقيد بهذه ال يعني ب
ب هذه
نعتبرها ضربه للقانون يعني
يعني هذه العمليه
ضرب لهيبه السياسه وضرب هيبه الديمقراطيه
وضرب هيبه القانون وبالتالي يجب ان يتساءل
الشعب التونسي هذا حزب بدا من الان يعني
يخرق هيبه السياسه هيبه الديمقراطيه هيبه
القانون فماذا
هذا الحكي يعني اه فيما يتعلق ب ما سميته
المال السياسي اه والذي ربما يوقف زحف
وسيله قانون منع الاثاره والاعلان السياسي
لماذا الان يعني المال السياسي مساله طرحت
منذ الاصفر في تونس وليس الان فقط
طرحناها منذ البدايه سيدتي الكريمه لانه
نعتبره انها اكبر خطر يتهدد الديمقراطيه
ان يصدق ان ان رجال الاعمال الذين يدفعون
اموالا ظاهره في هذا الحزب وفي احزاب اخرى
من يصدق ان هؤلاء الناس يدفعون هذا
الاستوديو حبا في الديمقراطيه هم يصدقون
يعني تسبق لهذه الاحزاب لتدافع عن اه اه
يعني عن مصالحهم اذا وصلوا الى السلطه
يعني بدا عمليه افساد الديمقراطيه من الان
لم ندخل الديمقراطيه ومن الان بدات فاقد
الشيء لا يعطيه وبالتالي فان اه يعني اولا
ا طالبوا الهيئه العليا الان بان تبت في
اه اقرار يعني اه ربما الطعن في حق هذا
الحزب في الترشح بما انه يخرق هيبه
السياسه وهيبه الديمقراطيه ولا يفصح عن
الاموال التي وراءها
تفضلي عفوا عفوا اكمل الشعب التونسي اعتبر
ان الشعب التونسي سيعاقب هذا الحزب وكل
الاحزاب المال السياسي والاشجار السياسي
وبالتالي سيعطيه حتى ندخل الديمقراطيه من
من اوسع بابو من امضى في باب
الشاب يعني تفضل الاستاذ ارد على هذا
الكلام اولا تفضلي اولا ان السيد منصف
المرزوقي يبدو انه لا يميز بين الهيئه
العليا لتحقيق اهداف الثوره
التي اعتبرها برلمان مصغرا وبين الهيئه
المستقله للانتخابات قرار منع الاخبار
السياسي صدر عن الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات ولم يصدر عن السنه وبرلمان
مصغرا توافقنا عليه هذا اولا ثانيا هذا
القرار هو ليس قانونا هو قرار
هيئه مستقله الانتخابات مع احترامنا
استقلاليتها الا انها ليست لهذه الصلاحيه
واود ان اقرا على مسامع مشاهدين الكرام ان
القرار هذا المؤرخ في 3 سبتمبر الحالي
الذي اصدرته الهيئه المستقله للانتخابات
في فصله الثاني يقول انه تمنع الدعايه
الانتخابيه في جميع وسائل الاعلام ابتداءا
من تاريخ اطناش تمنع الدعايه الانتخابيه
ولكننا نحن الان لسنا بصدد الدعايه
الانتخابيه نحن بصدد العمل الحزبي السياسي
والدعايه ل برامجنا وهناك خلط بين العمل
والدعايه الحزبيه وبين الحمله الانتخابيه
خلت في ذهن السيد المرزوقي وخلف في ان
العديدين الذين لم يذهبوا ولم يفرقوا بين
القوانين والقرارات القوانين في تونس
اليوم لا يمكن ان تحدث عنها الا في شكل
مراسيم يوفي عليها الرئيس المؤقت
للجمهوريه
وهذا لم يحدث الى حد الان ثانيا ان السيد
منصف المرزوقي يتحدث عن ظاهره المال
السياسي ويقول انه ان انه يطالب
ما يتعلق
ربما ال اه
غموض بعض المصطلحات فيما يتعلق بمنع
الدعايه او الاشاره السياسي يعني ان نص
حرفيا يقول منع كل اشكال الدعايه السياسيه
عبر الملصقات والاعلانات الاشاريه في
الاذاعه
والتلفزيون قبل بدء الحمله الانتخابيه
رسميا في واحد اكتوبر
هذا هو اطلاقا
لا ينطبق علينا لاننا نعتقد اننا بصدد حب
الانتخابيه الحمله الانتخابيه محدده في
المرسوم عدد خمسه وثلاثين سنه الفين
واحداث انها تبتدئ يوم 2 اكتوبر القادم
كيف مددت هذه الهيئه مع احترامنا لها اه
هذه المده اللي ترجع لها ثلاث اسابيع سته
اسابيع وكيف لا انت مني حزب سياسي ان يكون
بالدعايه بالتجمعات والتظاهرات والدعايه
والاعلانات لبرنامجه ورعاه انا اعتقد ان
هذه الهيئه
نفسها ولا تمتلكها
على الحياه العامه وعلى الحياه بينما هي
المكلفه بالاشراف على الانتخابات ومراقبه
الحمله الانتخابيه تحديدا ليس هناك لا لبس
ولا خلص في المصطلحات اريد ان نضيف للسيد
المر زوجي الذي تحدث وطالب ربما بات الحزب
الديمقراطي التقدمي لانه لم يمتثل لهذا
القرار وهو يعتبر خطا قانونا نحن نقول
تبارك الله هذه هي الديمقراطيه التي نشير
هنا بها السيد منصف المرزوقي انتقلنا من
شطب قائمه المعارضه وقائمه الحزب
الديمقراطي التقدمي وبين الديكتاتوريه الى
المطالبه بها من قبل رئيس حزب المؤتمر
الجمهوريه على
التقدمي يدخل
هو هو يطلب قائمتنا هذا ما قاله على ال هو
الان نحن نقول ان هذا
الوقت فقط اجابه مختصره لان لماذا ال
الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي يعني في طليعه
من تصدر اه اه اه قائمه الرافدين تقريبا
انتم وحدكم من رفض الالتزام بهذا القرار
لان الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي كان دائما
لا يتنازل عن حقوقه وجه الديكتاتوريه ولم
يمتثل للتعليمات والقرارات المنافيه
للقانون والتي اه تقلص من حقوقنا ومن مجال
تحركنا ايضا اليوم ولو صدر هذا القرار
انهى مستقل الانتخابات فان الحزب
الديمقراطي التقدمي لا يقبل للتنازل عن
حقوق وهو متمسك ب ممارستها كامله بحقه في
الاتصال بالمواطنين الثوره جاءت في تونس
بتفجر التقاتل تحرر الفضاءات ولن نقبل
تقييدا لها من
ولكن هنا نمثل للقانون ان تقيد في القانون
ولكن لا نلتزم ولا نطبق القرارات
والتعليمات
نواصل هذا النقاش بعد فاصل قصير مشاهدينا
في هذه الحلقه التي تتناول الجدل الدائر
في تونس حاليا حول وقف الحملات دعائيه
وحول صلاحيات المجلس التاسيسي تابعون بعد
فاصل قصير ارجو طبعا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في حلقتنا التي
تتناول الجدل الدائر في تونس حاليا بشان
صلاحيات المجلس التاسيسي الدكتور منصف
المرزوقي بخصوص ال مجلس تاسيسي وهذا ايضا
يعني اه
وهذا شان شائك جدا في تونس يبدو انه لم
يتم التوصل بعض الى التوافق حول
انتم من المناوئين ل اه اه وضع صلاحيات اه
اه للمجلس من خلال الاستفتاء وطلعونا
الاستفتاء ليس الا محاوله للالتفاف على
ثوره الشعب ودعوه الى ان يكون المجلس سيد
نفسه كامل الصلاحيات لانه منتخب من الشعب
كيف يمكن ان تقنع ال الطرف الاخر اه اه
بهذه القناعه
الشعبيه كل مره اخرى انا اطالب يكون باسم
تونس ان ترينا القائم ات ال رجال الاعمال
الذي يمولون حزبكم هذا حق من حق من حقوق
الشعب التونسي لان من يدخل الديمقراطيه
بالفساد والافساد فان الشعب الحق في
كان ذلك صحيحا
ينطبق عليه هذا القول
كل الاحزاب كل الاحزاب من حق من حقوق
الشعب التونسي انتشار الموارد التي تصرف
فيها وخاصه لها موارد كبيره وكبيره جدا
والاشهار ماله ظاهره عربيه المهم هو
اكشفوا الاموال التي هي وراء اكمل ان
والشعب اذا دخلت الديمقراطيه من باب
الفساد والافساد فان من حق اولا من حق
المنظمات ال ال القائمه الان على على اه
اه سلامه هذه الانتخابات الا ان تشطب هذه
القائمه ومن حق الشعب التونسي ان يشطب
عليها اذا مرت فيما يخص المجلس التاسيسي
السؤال السؤال الاوحد هو ما الذي يحتاجه
الشعب التونسي في هذه المرحله من تاريخيه
الشعب التونسي بحاجه الى الاستقرار بحاجه
الى الازدهار بحاجه الى الاصلاحات
الضروريه التي يجب ان نبدا فيها الان
عندما نقول انه المجلس التاسيسي ليس له
الا صلاحيات كتابه الدستور ويبقى السنه
هذا ان الاصلاحات معلقه منذ مده سنه معنى
هذا انه لا يوجد استثمار لانه لا يوجد
مستثمر قادر على الاستثمار في وضع
استثنائي في واقع انتقال يدوم سنه معنا
هذا ان سبعمائه الف بتطال يعني عاطل
العالم سيصبحون مليون اذن الشعب التونسي
مطالب يحتاج الى حكومه وحده وطنيه تدخل في
اصلاحات مباشره وبحاجه الى قوانين تعيد
صياغه البلد وبحاجه الى انتخابات بسرعه
وهي انتخابات بلديه لانه حاله البلد يعني
تعيسه جدا ونحن بحاجه الى الديمقراطيه
القاعديه وهي لا تكون الانتخابات البلديه
كل هذا يتطلب وقت اذن نحن نريد للمجلس
التاسيسي ان يكون كامل الصلاحيات ان يعيد
تاسيس البلد من الاصل يعني مفهوم المجلس
التاسيسي ليس كتابه الدستور وانما هو
اعاده تاسيس الدوله اعاده تاسيس المجتمع
وهذا يتطلب ان المجلس التاسيسي تكون له كل
الصلاحيات لانه حكومه وحده وطنيه تدوم
ثلاث او اربع سنوات لا يمكن ان تستند
الاعلى مجلس تاسيسي ثلاث او اربع سنوات
نحن بحاجه الى انتخابات البلديه ونحن
بحاجه الى وقتل كتابه الدستور الدستور ليس
هذا الدستور كتابه الدستور
نحن بحاجه الى النقاش المعمق حول الدستور
لان الاهم ليس النص المهم هو ان يستبدل
التونسيين هذا النص يجب ان يعني اولا
المجلس التاسيسي المكون من احزاب سياسيه
بينما المجتمع في مجتمعات مدنيه يعني نحن
نطالب ال اشراك المجتمع المدني في صياغه
الدستور اجراء النقابات الشعب الشباب هذا
يتطلب وقت يجب ان ناخذ وقتنا ايضا للنقاش
لان هذا سيؤسس الى تونس الغد ل ل لربما ل
قرن او قرنين وبالتالي نحن بحاجه الى
التاني واخذ كل الوقت ثم ان يكون هناك
نقاش مصطفى في التلفزيون فراج و على هذا
ال على هذا الدستور الذي سينظم كل تونس
امام الدوله وسيتم الدوله امام كل
التونسيين هذا يتطلب وقت وفي الاثناء
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه تشتغل وفي الاثناء
البلديات تشتغل ولنا الوقت الكافي لكي لكي
نتعمق في هذا ال العقل الجماعي الذي س
يربطون بعضنا البعض لمده قرون هم يريدون
مجلس تاسيسي ليس له الا كتاب ثم من سيحكم
طيله هذه السنه هي حكومه الوحده وهي حكومه
ديمقراطيه هذا هو السؤال
نعم اللي يرد لكن قبل ذلك التوضيح لانه
كان يتحدث باسم الشعب التونسي يطالبنا
باسم الشعب التونسي ولا اعتقد ان احد ان
كلفه بالحديث عنه السيد المذهبي اه بعيد
جدا عن فهم مقتضيات المرحله الديمقراطيه
هو حزب الى الان مع الاسف بقي كما كان
ظاهره صوتيه ولم يتحول الى حزب حقيقي عكس
الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي
نعم
ساتحدث الاستفتاء الحزب الديمقراطي
التقدمي تحول بعد الثوره الى حزب
الديمقراطي الجماهيري له من الامكانيات
والوسائل ما يمكنه من التصدي للمهام
التاريخيه المطروح عليه اليوم من في
البلاد بالنسبه لموضوع ال الاستفتاء نحن
في الحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي نرى ان مصلحه
البلاد تقتضي اختصار المرحله الانتقاليه
المقبله الى اقصى حد الممكن لذلك نقترح ان
لا تتجاوز هذه المرحله فتره السنه نحن
نعتقد ان المطلوب اليوم المهمه التاريخيه
الملقاه على عاتقنا هي اعاده بناء الشرعيه
في تونس وهذه الشرعيه لا يمكن اعاده
بنائها الا عبر سياتي دستور جديد لذلك نحن
نعتقد ان تحديد مده ومهام الهيئه المنتخبه
القادمه هي في صميم تحقيق اهداف الثوره
لان الوضع في تونس والوضع الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي في اعتقادنا لا يتحمل مزيدا من
الضبابيه ولا الاستقرار نحن في حاجه الى
حكومه شرعيه تكون تستمد قوتها من صناديق
الاقتراع ويكون بامكانها مواجهه التحديات
الكبرى التي تواجه البلاد
اما
تستمر الحكومه
نعم نحن سيدتي نحن نرى ان المجلس المنتخب
سيتولى انتخاب رئيسا مؤقتا جديد للبلاد
ونقترح ان يتولى هذا الرئيس تكليف شخصيه
مستقله
لتكوين حكومه تصريف اعمال حكومه انتقاليه
تتولى تصريف الاعمال بينما ينكب الفرقاء
السياسيين او المنتخبون صياغه الدستور
الجديد للبلاد حتى تتمكن تونس من اجتياز
هذه المرحله والمرور الى بناء مؤسسات
الدوله المستقره واستعاده الشرعيه ومن ثم
انتخاب حكومه يكون عندها الحقيقي هو الشعب
التونسي ويكون بامكانها اتخاذ القرارات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الضروريه التي
بامكانها وحدها مواجهه التحديات الكبرى
التي
عذرا للمقاطعه والاتفاق بهذا القدر معك
استاذ عصام الشابي لان وقت هذه الحلقه
انتهى يبدو ان هناك بدايه حل ربما تتمثل
فيما سمي باعلان الانتقال الديمقراطي
بديلا عن فكره الاستفتاء ستكون لنا مجالات
وفضاءات اخرى ارحب ل اه
النقاش وبحث هذه الحلول شكرا لضيفي ناكل
من الاستاذ عصام الشابي عضو المكتب
السياسي للحزب الديمقراطي التقدمي كنت
معنا من تونس ومن باريس الدكتور منصف
المرزوقي رئيس حزب المؤتمر من اجل
الجمهوريه
ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك وبهذا مشاهدينا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر غدا
باذن الله قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر
الجديد تحيه لكم اينما كنتم
[موسيقى]